for me to get better than that that's i
mean that was a huge show community was
a huge show so
funny because the whole time we were
like i think that's it yes
you know we were told numerous times at
the end of seasons they were like
hey can this last episode be the season
and series
finale like that's how like just the
confidence like the like the network
just going like
well we'll see we might have something
better
and uh unbelievable oh yeah you all
loved it you wanted to be there
we all knew we the hours were bananas
but we all knew because we would do
these table reads which were
uh so great and then i would stand up
and point
at the like the sony and the nbc
executives and i was like
do not change a word and then i'd walk
out
and and they were like hey you're like a
bully i'm like yeah i'm this
yes don't do it don't change
anything
and uh so yeah and they didn't you seem
like a guy that doesn't
uh really when you get mad everybody
goes oh there's a reason because
you don't seem like you get mad very
often if you lose your joel's upset
something's something's real right i am
amazing at
blowing up at inanimate objects like
that right there that
mask of if the mask was not staying up
on that thing
i might destroy it you might kill jason
voorhees
yesterday i was logging into a computer
i hadn't logged into
and i so i had you know you had to get
the code from your like
login to gmail and it said do you uh and
you put in and i
accidentally hit reset password and the
zoom call had started four minutes
earlier
and i screamed god damn it and my wife
came in
and she's like where's the emergency
and then you know when i explain it it's
i sound like an insane person
like well i accidentally pushed reset
password
this that merited me screaming and
uh she just rolled her eyes yeah she was
like uh-huh okay
well i'm gonna go uh you know deal with
the education of our children
so i'm gonna calm the kids down yeah i'm
gonna go take care of real life problems
so